ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: Hi.
I'm Adriana Cerundolo, program
manager for the global GDG
program.
So GDGs are Google
Developer Groups.
They're in-person meetups for
developers around the world
to learn about Google
Developer technologies.
We have over 600 chapters in
over 100 countries globally.
And these events, we
have over 7,200 of them
yearly, reaching over
35,000 participants.
So this year, we have over
500 of them here at I/O.
CROWD:[CHANTING] GDG!
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: So I have
a few GDG organizers here
with me, and we're going
to ask them what they're
going to bring back to I/O. Hi.
So Gino, you're from a
GDG chapter in Nigeria.
GINO OSAHON: Yeah.
GDG, Port Harcourt, Nigeria.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: What kind of
events do you run in Nigeria?
GINO OSAHON: We
organize tech events.
We organize user
experience events.
We organize events to bring good
developers from Port Harcourt.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: That's great.
And given the content
here at I/O this year,
what are you hoping to
bring back to your community
and teach them?
GINO OSAHON: One of the
things I've learned here
is how to better
manage a community.
So I'm going to back and see how
I can build a better community,
work very well with
my co-organizers,
get volunteers and other guys
that are interested in building
a good community,
and also introduce
good technologies that
could help developers
provide better solutions
to their clients over
in Port Harcourt.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO:
That's awesome.
Thank you so much.
GINO OSAHON: Thank you.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: I know we
have also another organizer
from Nigeria here, Chinedu.
Chinedu, talk to me
about what you're
hoping to bring back to
I/O, to your community
and any specific technologies
that you want to teach them.
CHINEDU CHUKWUELUE:
OK, it's been
a very beautiful experience
here out at the GDG summit.
The day one and day
two was awesome.
Day one we had CSI labs
and NVC communication.
That has taught me how to
be a better organizer, how
to manage my team better,
how to see people better.
On day two, we had
awesome breakout sessions,
and I learned how to manage the
community, how to teach people,
how to bring better
experiences to the community.
So what I'm taking back
home is a whole lot.
Because when I
get back home, I'm
going to make my chapter one
of the best in the GDG society.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: Thank you.
And also Timea from GDG Vienna.
What do you want to bring back
to your community from the I/O
content here today?
TIMEA TURDEAN: Hello.
I'm hoping to bring
back the enthusiasm
that I felt when the keynote was
on about all the new products
and technologies from
Google, especially
the Google Photos, which
I'm also very excited about,
and the new Android
M, so super cool.
And also to the
organizing team in Vienna,
I'm hoping to bring
back very good examples
of how to improve our events,
like DevFest and Women
Techmakers.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: Nice.
TIMEA TURDEAN: Thank you.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO:
So clearly if you
want to learn more about
Google Developer technologies,
just go ahead and
find one near you.
Woohoo!
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
CROWD: [CHANTING] GDG!
[MUSIC PLAYING]